los testigos en el juicio de benjamín
netanyahu empezaron a testificar pero el
primer ministro de israel no se quedó de
la corte para seguir la audiencia los
jueces le permitieron irse después de la
declaración inicial del fiscal el primer
caso examinada es el caso 4000 en el que
netanyahu enfrenta el cargo por
corrupción uno de los más graves y donde
se alega que llegó a un acuerdo con el
accionista más grande de la mayor
empresa de telecomunicaciones del país
el líder israelí aparentemente otorgó
favores a cambio de una cobertura más
favorable por parte del portal de
noticias de los accionistas iguala el
primer testigo fue el director de la
página en internet en ese momento en el
caso mil
netanyahu está acusado de aceptar
champán puros y otros artículos de lujo
por un valor de cientos de miles de
dólares de dos multimillonarios a cambio
de favores fiscales el caso 2000 lo
acusó de negociar un trato con el
principal propietario de un periódico de
israel para obtener una mejor cobertura
pero netanyahu ha negado haber actuado
mal más su medio mes por lo que se está
juzgando hoy es el intento de frustrar
del pueblo el intento de derrocar me y a
la derecha a pesar de las acusaciones en
su contra hasta ahora sigue siendo
primer ministro después de la corte se
reunirá con el presidente con la
esperanza de obtener un mandato para
formar el próximo gobierno italiano
podría enfrentar años de prisión si es
declarado culpable en este caso hay más
de 300 positivos pero es probable que el
juicio y las apelaciones de seguimiento
demoren años mientras tanto el líder
israelí no está obligado legalmente a
dimitir